okay bad legal take alert this time from  famed director rob reiner who writes fox  news is spreading of disinformation and  lies about vaccines or causing people to  die legal experts must find someone with  standing to file a lawsuit well a couple  issues here yeah standing would probably  be an issue here but the bigger problem  is that there's no claim that you can  make you can find someone with standing  but  you're not going to be able to make a  claim against them because of that thing  called the first amendment you might  disagree with the things that people are  saying but under the first amendment  you're allowed to lie as long as you're  not defaming an individual specifically  and a lot of these things are going to  go down as just their opinions so you  might disagree with someone's opinion  but again that's why the first amendment  exists so that we have a marketplace of  ideas so sorry rob your movies are great  but your legal takes are not